hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at Wario's or
at least the last night of five nights
at Wario's so I shall be determined to
beat and show you guys the ending of
because I got the mouse on a little
table here magical super gaming table of
extraordinary skill that I have I don't
need a keyboard why do I even have it
hello speak up so I can shut you up
really quickly
hello oh yes please shut up okay so now
all the game is on game is on now I'm
ready cuz everyone's gonna be a giant
dick bag but I got my skill here up to
maximum intensity and everyone's gonna
bow before my massive skill where I'm
willing to die either way I'm gonna be
able to react a little bit quicker this
done that's all I really want whoa hey
there friend no you're not supposed to
be over there you're supposed to be like
in my computer screen where you're I can
reliably count on you being in one place
oh there you are I didn't actually mean
for you to be there you know I didn't
actually want that I was just kind of
insinuating that you might want to do
that just for my convenience god damn I
still can't click if I could just do
this correctly it's really hard to click
on things correctly by the way everybody
shush I need to focus huh damn stop it
can't click correctly
I don't know how Mario behaves I have
not seen a single other dude they're not
animal products I gotta remember that
there's kind of dudes there's a dude
whoa what are you doing what does that
mean what I mean what does that mean
does it mean when you blink it stopped
blinking
mumbling Mario say five nights of war
Mario's is five nights warriors I can't
even remember what I'm trying to say
yeah okay go up go down okay check check
no one's here your trick didn't work on
me I'm only wasting a lot of power how
is it only silk well god this sucks
oh it's gonna be a long night god I'm
suck
down so much power trying to keep these
guys at bay okay there's Wario do I even
need to look at the screen anymore do I
really need to do that because Mario
doesn't seem to be able to change unless
I do that and the only time that people
seem to be a threat to me is if they're
at the windows which kind of leads me to
believe that the only time that their
guys are gonna be a threat is if I'm
actually looking at the thing what's a
mistake in here I mean I am totally okay
with sitting in this room going back and
forth forever and ever
that's that's what security cards to
okay that's what I get paid for at least
I'm assuming I get paid I'm gonna play
by your game all right cool
that's great good for you that peach
clip-clopping around
[Music]
what if someone change their mind did
Mario get closer
Rosetta's me now I didn't now well I
didn't have the screen up I don't think
anyway haha I'm not playing your game
right nice just to be a good sport you
never know what nothing nothing
you ain't got no thing it's not really
anything new I gotta admit be da putty
daddy
yeah it eat it cuz I'm pretty sure I've
already seen everything that I want to
see on the screen I kinda just want to
beat the game move on cuz I mean this is
this is probably a good five nights at
Freddy's clone but I also don't want to
just over saturate everything with five
nights at Freddy's stuff I only wanted
to beat this because people want to see
the end of it and people want a bit of a
challenge so I will deliver henceforth
blah blah king of 5 nights at freddy's
or what-have-you
maybe probably not I bet I relinquish my
crown to those that managed to beat to
10:20 mode way before I did cuz I took a
long time to do it you know it's funny
story I what after I beat 1020 modes
like right after I beat 1020 mode I
messaged Gerard the completionist
projared the completion the the finisher
Pro Gerard the finisher sorry I keep
forgetting his actual full name well I
messaged him on Twitter and I basically
thought dude oh right I basically typed
in all bulb caps do not try to beat 1020
mode like that's literally the advice
they gave him and i got a mate it was
probably good advice
that guy gone yet I didn't hear much
squeaky was I was shouting over it it's
gonna be a problem
oh crap okay that was lucky I don't know
if it's gonna be able to shut me down if
that happens don't really know what I'm
supposed to do now
well I kind of got a lonely a little bit
of time left I'd rather not screw it up
now take a look around
hello Petey you're looking fine daddy
way go away check way thank you
I am rubbernecked aren't I I'm scrubber
dude scribbly dumped scruffy bleep um
maybe I'm not I've got a lot of power I
might be able to just ride this one out
which would make him that five nights at
Wario's isn't very well balanced but I
don't care at this point I just want to
say I beat it because I am currently at
PAX is that what you say huh gone
whoa peach hey hey didn't know Pete
who's there I'm almost done oh you're
not there I'm gonna win ya one what
prize do I get I bet there's another man
just knowing these games I bet there's
another secret night who should secret
no one no wait what and then Richard
McRoy typed in Comic Sans left okay I'm
done then well alright well the game
exited just gone like that
great now you all get to see the game
grumps is amazing but that's it I didn't
even read what the end of it was I
didn't even die I got mad I'm a little
disappointed I was able to cheat my way
through that I was because there's a
little bit of a knot problem if you
don't look at it you know you kind of
get through the game without looking at
the thing and I feel like a cheap
through it I want to die - peach once I
want to die - peach I'm gonna go die -
peach I'm gonna see if I can somehow get
it to make me die - peach I got a thing
for peach wait wait 96 ha ha ha I knew
it I knew there had to be something I
knew it
Oh night 6 baby got a call from me baby
oh no the game is on right now all the
game is on right now Wow holy Hsiung
kurz alright I'll play the game
legitimately this done
but if peach is coming I'm gonna let her
jump all over me if you know what I mean
not none that way not that way I'm just
saying I'm gonna let her jump my bones
but not in that way what are you talking
about why you got to make it sexual
I mean honestly why you gotta make it
sexual it's not sexist just two friends
one human one ghost video game character
I want her to kill me what
weird about that you're weird get out of
here no don't go but get out here with
those ideas that's silly Billie's is so
silly out there
oh yeah Mario I was going I wasn't
talking about your girlfriend in any
weird way like I'm not a weirdo
Mario I am a totally normal totally sane
dude okay I see you giving me attitude
there Mario I see you getting close to
me but you gotta understand to be killed
by imaginary women you guys know what I
mean you guys back me up in the cops
back me up in the comments below if you
know what I'm talking about or if you
don't know what I'm talking about and
you think it's like 2:00 in the morning
I'm just rambling for the sake of
rambling because I got nothing else to
say so I'm kind of just moving my mouth
and everything coming out of my brain
and one even flow yeah maybe not I don't
know you don't know I don't know it's
night six or five days of warriors and I
I'm gearing up trying to recoup Oh ready
poop poopy poop I ain't gonna do it
what's gonna happen huh
what if I don't what if I don't want to
died Wario get war you stupid I love dad
why are you on I want peach to gobble my
giblets not in that way
not not dirty you're dirty get your mind
out of the gutter okay your minds in the
gutter you need lift it up take it out
of the gutter put it somewhere else
okay dirtiness you got clean it you know
clean it a bit shake your mind out dump
it out and put it in not gutter anywhere
I bought the gutter way cleaner than the
gutter don't know why the gutters that
dirty I'm rambling do y'all ready to die
God Wario weren't peach cooming peach
wouldn't even dare yet I don't even know
if something's gonna happen if I be 96
but you know how I bet I can beat it by
just opening the game and sitting there
that's why I'm uh that's why I'm on do
you guys want to see you at 6 beaten
this is how you doing
let me show you how a pro does it I'm
not just buying time whatever shut up
[Music]
damn it it was pizza and I wanted to dye
my peach oh well I'm almost at the end
of the game so I'm just gonna ride it
out I'm gonna win and then a winner's
circle I will stand in and everyone will
cheer my name and scream it from the
mountaintops
oh this haribol fate I shall suffer well
I shall bear it because I'm a man you
guys think it equally barren if I was a
woman but either way I'm gonna bear it
there we go 5 no gun hit the escape
button accidentally I am loopy if you
couldn't tell it's very late I'm very
tired I have a bit of a temple headache
and I don't know I just got nothing yeah
I did it what do I win I beat night 6
really hard I was actually playing the
games and sitting there you are not
allowed to enter the factory when it's
closed and never do that again
congratulations that's it that's it well
I guess it's some you know even though I
was making fun of it towards the end
like I think it's just because me the
the specific formula of what it was was
not all that scary to me because there's
even though it's five nights of Freddy's
you know clone it's not exactly the same
as what the original is he didn't have
the same fine-tuning to it that the
original did it didn't have the same
polish the original game that being said
it's still not bad like I can't say that
it's bad it has a creative idea and it
really took it to an interesting
direction even though that same
direction landed in the same spot as
five nights at Freddy's it still took
this concept of putting a creepypasta
style world into an environment that
worked with the recipe and the recipe
being five minutes right it worked with
it it was not bad I liked it I give it
my Marga bar stamp of approval good job
there buddy whoever made it I think it
was wwr you made it congratulations you
made a decent game that got my stamp of
approval
haha so thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the other stuff that
I've done in the description below I'll
put
totally randomized videos something
you've never seen before and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]